[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
i met that dude really yeah he came to
uh i was opening for
trevor wallace in san jose oh he came to
the show there you do yeah he's buried
he i didn't know who he was you didn't
like no and he was just
hey man you're funny i'll say oh thanks
dude he's just chilling in the green
room
had no clue to [ __ ] i don't know who
we're talking about bring it up say
oh chin's taking a [ __ ] you never heard
us
in start i'll be right back
i was like start i'll be back
you've never seen him before oh okay
like jordan sparks for a hot minute
he what he dated jordan sparks for a hot
minute he was he dating right now he had
like a beef going on with his girl and
they were fighting
and he had to apologize hey you like to
apologize
yeah i don't think so i think you're
thinking lincoln park with jay-z
that's encore though right yeah that
sounds hard
wait how about how about that doing
spokane brought uh those that lincoln
park toy in the the billy madison toy
oh yeah where is it my son was like oh
you got toys
cool oh and broke the boxes open and i
look over and he's taking him going
dude those are my toys how does he's
like he's like you got me surprised dad
i'm like
no yeah and then i looked down like oh
you got my toys
damn he's like the madison one was
pretty cool yeah i wanted to bring in
here before he ruins it i'll probably
try and bring it wednesday but he
already opened it
yeah damn they're good in the in their
little box i know well they're worth
money
i guess you leaving the box we missed
you for a second
we didn't think we would need you
immediately and then
we needed you how how dope did well
chin you've never been to coeur d'alene
idaho right they hate when you talk
about it because they want to keep it a
secret you're not a secret
no no no cortland's dope though huh so
we did we quiet
we played spokane comedy club but we
didn't stay in spokane because we don't
do meth
so then we stayed in coeur d'alene which
is like
30 minutes 40 minutes 30 40 minutes 40
minutes
you get a fish right off the dock yeah
right off the idaho yeah
idaho idaho's amazing fishing i want to
go there yeah remember we were going to
go to
before but then it was like snowing so
there would only be ice fishing
not this like so the it was a lake house
you know straight up quarterly
yeah and there were people fishing i was
like i would love
oh yeah it would have been cool you ever
been in alaska for fishing no that's
another dream of mine yeah
my my adopted folk side my grandpa
uh he him and his buddies my
grandmother you know what i'm trying to
say yeah
uh they go they do like a fishing trip
to alaska
eminence bloods like i think like every
year that's beautiful you gotta go do it
so much it was it was so much it was
nice weather and uh
coordinators i mean only it was raining
a little bit you know it was only warm
when we initially got in
and then like the rest of the year on
saturday wasn't bad saturday morning
yeah well it was great nice
it was sunny yeah what hey buddy i
thought we were bundled up though
we've oh yeah
[ __ ] yeah you don't know the oj story so
he started watching us oh yeah i
obviously i know the [ __ ] surface
level [ __ ]
i got my master's degree yeah you got
your mask he's got his masters in oj
i'll go through the whole
thing yeah yeah guys i saw that because
yeah they completely changed that uh
house
oh yeah you talking about where she was
murdered yeah yeah that town
house yeah i drove by it you drove by on
this anniversary i drove by it
whose
knocked it all down because they because
they don't want dumbasses
to drive by all the time well because
that's what was happening i guess
yeah i guess that's what like it was
just such a [ __ ]
touristy it's weird when you go those
murder sites like i went to
charles manson where they murdered
champagne can't wait what's the point
because i like because i read so i don't
know why i'm into i read so much about
it
i want to visually see like the historic
darkness that went down so like when i
drove to sharon tate's house
it's creepy man because i know okay
because i i study it so much
i know exactly where tex walks in park
the car i know the walk they made
so you can read about it but when you
like when you're there like you can park
where he parked
when you're there and you're like what
that it's just weird yeah no i can't
like put it all together
and you can see they all right they
parked here at the end of the hill they
walked up hill
here murder cheering tate and the folger
and the rest of her
it's nuts you feel like a pi i know
right yeah you're super
i i get scared like it it's creepy as
[ __ ] man
it is really really creepy all that
shit's creeping and i i
i don't know well that book got been
the night stalker book it's like the the
balls deep in the night stalker they get
into like
the murders and hit him in prison and
all this stuff
what was weird with that nightstalker
stuff the murders are so intense it's so
scary
i wouldn't read it on my own like i get
scared sometimes it's so graphic i put
the book down
i'm like [ __ ] why do i read this stuff i
put it down and then like an hour go by
on the fly i'm like let me see this [ __ ]
i only have like 50 pages left but it's
scary man
you were reading it when we were on the
uh we were coming from cleveland
yeah that started in cleveland i'm
almost done with it now it's spoken
because i only read on i can't read at
home my kids like get the [ __ ] out of
here
so i only read on planes but then uh
what's weird about him is like
gets busted clearly he's the murderer
there's evidence all over from a shoe
print to his dna
he's because he'd rape him so his
evidence is all over the place
and his family was like there's no way
he did this so his family come visit him
and he's like they're framing me they're
framing this is ridiculous i didn't do
this
they're just trying to put on a poor
mexican kid his family's like yeah
that's right
like what the [ __ ] like look just look
at all and then
he would murder people and ask for you
know jewelry and cash before he murdered
him
then he would take that jewelry wedding
rings bracelets necklaces that are
specific to that person they murdered
and send to a sister
so they went to a sister's house and
like has has the
night starter giving you any jewelry and
she was like yeah
and they're like let us see so they open
up it's all the people that's been
murdered jewelry
she's like i don't believe he did it
it's like are you out of your [ __ ]
mind like that
like they're just show by the oblivious
because it's their brother he was like
the little brother
like there's no way he did it then even
when he was in prison
he was like i'm just going to say guilty
and they're like no you got to fight
this because you're innocent and you
could tell he was like
yeah they're just going to frame me so
i'm [ __ ] either way he's like i'm say
guilty because
obviously he's guilty yeah and then he
had so many hoes coming after him
so many hoes like they said the wardens
like the security of the prison were
like we've never seen anything like this
so many girls want to [ __ ] him they
thought it was so like you so
handsome no conjure no visits he could
talk to him on the phone
and like he got he had like die hard
like ride or die [ __ ]
so weird right it's weird that you read
it
yeah i don't know why well when cat was
at the house
when cows at house the new book team
says why are people so in love with
serial killers
because i'm trying to figure out that's
a there's a book about that yeah i got
them yeah brendan i just got it and
trying to figure out why
is there other people out there that's
infatuated with serial killers well
i hear you i hear you but driving up to
people
this is absolutely this is episode 666 i
know what i'm saying you wanted to go to
that [ __ ] hotel
again you talking about him but again
here's what's interesting
i'd see jay was like hey a lot of people
emailed firing the kid
shop at gmail.com a lot of people you
know hotels you can't
get yeah yeah you can't go there i was
not able to book anything so i don't
know what's happening you said
yeah people were dming me and saying
yeah you
that's what they want to tell off maine
now
stay on main or something like that yeah
i'll stay on maine yeah yeah man they
changed the name
it'd been fun to do it but man it's just
when you look more into it dude
you want to talk about a terrible
[ __ ] person yeah i mean yeah what
about that girl at the uh water tower
uh that's mental health yeah shout out
to mental health betterhelp.com promo
code shop
that's all that she's just wait she's on
she was on meds well that's the thing
that kind of like
you know looking at that story it's like
people want to say she was like
demonized and stuff like that it's like
crazy man like and
meanwhile her folks yeah are sitting
here saying no she really
but look at the conspiracy is way more
fun to say
yep because what actually happened is
she was on medication didn't take her
meds she had these
crazy episodic things happen before
where they find her under beds terrified
think somebody's chasing her
she decides to take a truck and you know
journey
down to california goes to all these
spots yeah stop taking her medication
she just happens to be at that creepy
hotel didn't take her meds
wanders off climbs in the water tower
they didn't think they'd look in the
[ __ ] water tower they found her crazy
ass and they're dead
okay saul yeah mental illness man look
how big
there was there was someone that uh
broke it down and they were like it's so
easy to get into that water tower
yeah they they literally had their
phones and they got they got
they're getting sued for it because it
shouldn't be that easy yeah and then
they're like well why was the top
closed when they found her how would a
person drown they closed the top
and then the the janitor was like well i
was checking the watch out and i opened
it
saw she's in there freaked out and
closed it oh
yeah he was like in case all like i
closed it yeah
people like no you did it i don't know
she's demonized yeah and i'm like man
that's mental health man
yeah i mean like crazy yeah all right
brendan you're just saying like
case saw people really believe in that
stuff though it's so
fun dude wrong i love it it's so fun
uh-huh but it's yeah but the charles
manson one's even weird
the charles benson wants to meet the
most strange case there is
because he was doing he was an
experiment with the cia with lsd
and in ashburton he had
he was out on parole he would violate
his pro all the time
and people like hey man charles manson's
right there like he violated all these
pearls go arrest them
and every cop in that county like no
like we're
it's higher up than this we're not
allowed to [ __ ] with them you're like
why wouldn't they [ __ ] why why can't
they [ __ ] with them
it's just that charles manson's [ __ ]
a weird case dude
fury chaos by uh i forget the author
it's
it brenda you think i'm gonna read these
books it'd be good i didn't even want to
go to that damn hotel
yeah i'm definitely not i didn't after i
read what uh
because you know when you watch the
documentary on night stalker
it kind of gives you just how bad he is
there it is that that book that's the
best serial killer book in the world
best serial killer book it's the most
important whole sentence it's the most
interesting book you will ever read
ever as far as charles manson's free
review the best book of all time
it's it's it's i couldn't put it down
it's [ __ ] captivating
so the cia had their hands on charles
yes and the
regular police couldn't touch him yep
well it did get a 4.8 out of 5. his
parole officer
in san francisco like helped him out and
they let it it just it doesn't make
sense
it doesn't make it all of it doesn't
make sense and then i'll like the whole
narrative
that that the real famous book came out
that uh
not pelosi jesus christ i forget the guy
who wrote it oh uh
helter skelter helped his counter i
heard it man helter skelter
was the book that the prosecutor uh
vince vincent uh booga boogaliosi
bugaloosi
he wrote it and this was also his
defense saying that
you know he started a race war and you
know he was into the beatles and he did
it to create all this race stuff
and then charles manson's like i don't
like the beatles he's like that's the
beach boys guy
see i don't listen to [ __ ] beatles he
was like that makes sense dude
so like he painted this whole narrative
yeah that he's crazy and he
launched this race warning he's like
what he's like
so why do you put the swastika on his
head just to look crazy
because he there's a point when he was
on trial he's like oh i'm never getting
up so i'm just going to lean into the
crazy [ __ ]
but they also try to make him look crazy
because he you
may have you see him in those those
videos has really long hair in the beard
he's like i asked oh yeah my haircut and
shave
so i look like a [ __ ] normal person
but they want they wouldn't let me
because they knew i looked [ __ ] crazy
brittany you balls deep in this [ __ ]
what else do you like well hold on
before you ask that question before you
ask that question what are your other
interests
this might be a weird question but let
me ask you brendon get me started on
[Laughter]
well who's the best serial killer in
your mind because i asked what i know
it's a weird question
because it's the balls the btk killer
was
[ __ ] pretty gruesome he he didn't get
caught forever but the number
the best as far as if you were to say
best like most
deaths was this guy who worked in an old
folks home in hospital
because you know old people they die
yeah but
he would be like oh cool and then just
like someone's grandma cover their nose
and mouth
kill and be like oh man she passed away
this is so sad and then he came out and
was like
they finally killed like 80 people like
[ __ ] you killed my grandma
she was going anyway yeah he's like the
most as far as
successful circular all the time he was
so hard to track
can't they tell that though no so how do
you tell
bro you can't like oh no no
no because they were they're on
ventilators like breathing meant because
they had
issues breathing already yeah so he just
unhook it this this
this the [ __ ] yeah right there's 50
patients yeah you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] coward coward yo i can't be so yeah
go to different nursing homes
take their man my grandmother
this one says uh 15 patients care with
his total
total number is 250. 250 people well
they can't think about they couldn't
figure out your grandma goes there and
she's like on her last leg
and like yeah stay less and then just
[ __ ] kill him well he looked like he
was on his last leg and look at this
then no one checked into it because
they're just old people so he got away
with it
forever this was in the uk who was
keeping count
he was he'll just kill an old person
he looked normal he had like a family
was he was he
executed that way
man that's that guy from always sunny
and in philadelphia
don't you dare compare him to danny
devito how dare you
how dare you he he was johnny devito
is a gift he was awful he was what now
what was his deal
bound torture kill so he would he would
uh tie the people up
and then while he's raping oh yes that's
one of his victims
he put mask on him and [ __ ] he'd wear
weird [ __ ] but he was married
and so he would like he would kill and
then his wife suspected so he went on a
break
was he was he like five years later
bad bad dude piece of [ __ ] wow
yeah yeah that is weird is it was he a
cop b because he
is that him down there on the right no
uh sorry right there in the middle
is that him right there no that looked
like him
maybe it's not him or maybe that's the
person that caught him
no that that is him that is him was he a
cop
what is yeah what is his outfit fine
torture kill 10 people
wichita kansas and wha what around
this was in the 90s no it has to be 80s
they said the 80s at the bottom
oh is that guy dead
hopefully real piece of [ __ ] tennis
bam i never heard of these uh killers at
all yeah right
creepy stuff well what's weird is the
narrative that uh
ted bundy's like this handsome serial
killer it's like
ted bundy was smart like he he is he
handsome
i don't not not compared to you know
this is weird to say but not compared to
uh ramirez maybe let me be the judge
do you think he was handsome for the
time and like where he was killing like
those
areas like he was good looking like you
know how there's like a la and then like
a
which he's a cleveland you know he's
like a cleveland seven
he did it in cleveland he did oh he did
it cleveland utah oh he went he went
uh got it he went places but he was
handsome so he charmed girls in the
house
i don't know
i don't think ted is that handsome but
he's not like zac efron played him in
the
movie on netflix zac efron's a dime
piece
yeah oh yeah he's he's
compared to richard ramirez i think it's
his jawline or something yeah
richard ramirez is those those blue eyes
you're right
dude but richard ramirez that long hair
crying
richard ramirez oh man no a compared oh
come on dude oh hold on
it's the hair yeah yeah he's a good
looking dude yeah he looked like the guy
from american horse wait who's that girl
he's
that is that he actually uh added him in
as a character yeah he was in the 1970s
one what
yeah 1989 that was like the first
american no that was the first
that was the last one
but as far as like if we're talking
about good looking serial killers he's
numero who knows
son yeah that's the thing that's the
thing some of the girls that he raped
they didn't kill
they weren't describing them he was a
very good looking
latino guy wait when did he get his
teeth fixed
why he was impressed so they thought he
was hot with bad teeth
but they said he was very attractive to
open his mouth and that's when
that's one of the ways he got caught he
had like all these cavities and his
teeth were all [ __ ] up and
he went to a dentist in uh koreatown and
he's supposed to come back
so they had cops wait in there and
pretend they were waiting
but he never came like he was privy to
it he was hot to it so never came back
but there oh yeah like he's gonna have
to figure out his teeth because he's in
so much pain
yeah he's good looking and you know what
he you know what he was a big uh rock
fan so
before murders he'd listen to ac dc
highway to hell
and he had a dope ac dc hat and then he
killed one person's hat fell off
brynden yeah you're an encyclopedia for
this well yeah what book is like people
infatuated with serial killers
yeah yeah how deep are you into that
i've even started
trying to finish this one it is it is
interesting
like these [ __ ] murder mystery docs
on [ __ ] netflix are like
so [ __ ] popular dude well i have no
idea the number one podcast
ain't rogan ain't [ __ ] fighting a kid
ain't king of sting
ain't bad friends not crystalia it's
it's
uh crime murder mystery really it's like
serial
the apology line like that stuff the
biggest like demo dude
because you have all like housewives and
[ __ ] listening to it not just 18 to 36
bros
like there's so many more like just but
i thought i thought it was a lot of
females that like to listen to that they
do like my mom
i don't know why i am interested in my
dateline and [ __ ] well when i was like a
kid i'd watch my mom let me watch like
freddy krueger
and like good fella like yeah killing it
but again like you meet people like
brendan or my mom you would never
suspect that they're any kind of my mom
watched snap
religiously i'm like girl these are all
episodes like snap is like women who
like snapped and they kill her husband
killed her husband all right and i was
like why you keep watching watching this
she was like
is it uh is it a scripted series no it's
not scripted it's like real talk
oh it's it's yeah what yeah
is it like that is it like it's a white
halo movie enough enough
but she she beat him up that [ __ ] was so
unrealistic
she trained for a little bit she already
she's drinking
she came for two weeks and then she's
like i'm ready
put on the hand wrapped him up and then
he came in there and she was like yeah
she [ __ ] him he was like oh you want
to go and then
my favorite buddy's like you want to go
she's awful she tried to do ls [ __ ] she
was awful
wow hey some people can learn a lot
about it
[Applause]
are you serious i haven't you got to
check it out i won't tell you what i've
had enough of
what you cheating on your diet oh i was
talking like i'm cheating on my diamonds
everyone's like you're looking a lot
slimmer let's talk about it though
actually that's like because i had a
[ __ ] sticky bun
yeah oh yeah so how about him and jay go
to breakfast with
malik who's that you you just asked
history yeah and jay suddenly goes these
sticky buns are ridiculous and i
specifically touched you i went don't
let chappelle eat those
no one's commented back nothing and then
later in the green room jay's like you
know chappelle had a sticky no no
no no he didn't tell you i told you
told me you had the mcdonald's cookies i
didn't have no mcdonald's cookies yeah
you did
you do i was about to say let's not do
that jamie rashford
cause that's just so hard i know you're
[Applause]
he doesn't mean to because someone
delivered postmates to mcdonald's you
set
him up you said like you said
of like 60 cookies and a happy meal
while he's on someone
is brendan yeah and then i came back and
i'm like damn i love those mcdonald
cookies like they're all warm and gooey
and i saw you like doesn't this sound
like a trap oh yeah i even said yeah i
was like yeah they had the cookies bro
the cat doesn't just sound like a trap
someone just magically delivers us
like while brenda's on stage yeah three
chicken sandwiches
two mc mcdonald's uh cookies
and uh 38 30 chocolate chip cookies
and three large fries and a uh diet coke
no one in the audience
i also want to add that i don't think
you're to blame because stevie told me
the entire weekend it was hard to get
food
so it's not like it was an area where
you could get something healthy quickly
so if that's the only thing you have i
don't blame you wait hold on context
matters
really i really hate caffeine really
yeah
i didn't have any cookies you was on
stage you were also i
got back they were still there you know
what i ate chipotle in the rice
i ate chicken and rice no stutter no
they make you feel guilty
don't do that
we gotta lock it up man it's tough when
you're three weekends in a row listen
and i've been doing fine and then what
if i wanted to have one sticky bun
balance one and i had one cookie brownie
you had a sticky bun
no i had a i had a piece of sticky i
didn't eat the whole sticky bun
but then guess who missed the workout
this morning oh and who's going to work
and what'd you do and what'd you do i
told him
he missed a workout time out hey man i'm
not going to make it at 8 am i'm going
to breakfast
that is true god
eggs and spinach like i always do that's
a good breakfast yeah thank you very
much you are not sure i'm buying that
you don't have to buy it ready you're a
girl i know what i'm doing
you're laughing what'd you have would
you have no i just told you
i
did you guys split just a little
cinnabon or something i don't eat
cinnabons yeah
right just sticky bugs
i know you [ __ ] up
what'd you eat this morning it has a
protein drink and uh that almond butter
oh [ __ ] damn i ain't got no bro yeah you
went to the gym too
oh yeah yeah he was in the gym solo mark
left this time i'm seeing my family
what the [ __ ] yeah you can see your
family on the weekend mark yeah mark you
know our schedule dude you know the
[ __ ] skills kind of trainer just dips
out oh i gotta see my mama
damn you know we're gone thursday
through [ __ ] sunday so his
his schedule revolves around y'all's
schedule one house i'll tell you what i
thought
i don't have any coke if i did i had
done it yesterday we i had a 7 a.m
flight
we got zero sleep got about three hours
of sleep
landed around 9 30 got home at 10. my
girl's like oh
tiger's best friend's birthday parties
today oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
said i'm with boston tiger at this
[ __ ] birthday party basically doing a
podcast with the parents there
dude yeah i'm glad we kept dude we were
on that the plane we had yesterday
from uh spokane to [ __ ] portland got
a layover
dude it was one of those [ __ ]
tiny hey you know it's 2c so chappelle i
mean chappelle always want the window
seat
i'm like it's not enough room for us
chapel and i'd be leaning like yeah be
liam i'm like god dude
but it was pretty it was pretty well
i've never been on but then the plane
from portland l.a you're good
it was regular oh yeah that propeller
one was pretty funny it was a little
shaky
that's like the flight to miami is no
punk now
this week thursday three weeks is too
much man too much no only probably goes
since the end of
february i don't know that's why he
missed the workout
and that's what yeah i just wanted to
spend a little time with my girl is that
fine
that's cool y'all both looking slimmer
though i saw that picture
oh yeah it's okay to have a cheat day
yeah hey honey right he acts like i do
it every day
well that's old me well that was you
dude that's old me you didn't told me
they told me
you told me you're right all right
you're right you hear me i heard you
told me
it's you yeah did you see i i post that
picture me go like this for three sold
out shows in one day
and uh whoever has the best caption i'll
give two tickets to miami
someone goes it's like this and the best
caption goes uh
uh that's how many pounds brendan's lost
and started at zoo three
i know the pictures of the beggar shout
out to jared man
though uh johnny picked the winner the
winner but uh
how many more inches is stevie than you
oh three
[Laughter]
oh three dude i i've really liked uh
spokane was probably my favorite uh
crowd some of my favorite crowds
great grass they were great i love
spokane
it was i mean i'm glad we didn't really
stay out there you know
because we pulled up and it was yeah
back flip i know right every [ __ ]
time with the gold chain on mm-hmm
that was when we said justin looked like
a the [ __ ] worm
yeah i said justin looks like the
reading worm yes
and we look back at the reading word and
someone
watching is create him as the reading
word
go to i said justin bill like the
reading worm
he has the same head
but you gotta go when he has the glasses
on it's ready he does because he has
this
yeah yeah go to justice profile it's
just an uncut uncut
yeah we're laughing so hard oh my god
that's [ __ ] hilarious
just an uncut remember when justin was
like man
you know going to work all the way down
he was talking about yeah man i need to
i need to get back going
to get back on you've never started
[Laughter]
you and justin eat the exact same and
y'all eat what do you mean like
hey white justin but tempeh improv was
magical last night hashtag never stop
hashtag never quit
what what never stop what
stand up this is a motivational
idea
[Laughter]
no one's saying you can't dude oh the
mark harley
oh man that's wait no actually justin
eats worse than you
justin justin it's like my son tiger he
loses
apple juice lemonade chicken tenders
chips
get mad at you for taking your chips yup
you brought up so many chips somebody's
battery eating yeah like uh what else
you eating [ __ ]
yeah and i'll be like damn dude i
thought you were working on your diet i
am dog i'm gonna start next week
oh yeah yeah we said that last week it
was funny looking at him and watching
him at the gym because he wasn't really
doing anything he didn't know what to do
he didn't know what to do
i saw him pick up a dumbbell and like
turn it like this
he was on the leg machine just sitting
there he called me he called me
stevie came over hey justin what the
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
i saw him on the lap press down
and then go tell us man i need to get
back on it
how you calling me out last night he was
like man i'm about to get swole on your
hoes i'm tired of being elected the
smallest in the clique
yeah but he could get like shredded with
his body type like because he's an
ectomorph for sure he could get shredded
you think if he ate right and just got
lean he'd look dope man
i wonder what he looks like when he
played basketball in college the exact
same
are there any pictures
why you looking at me a little bit
because you know i have pictures in
college do you have pictures you just
didn't play in basketball
pictures you in college yeah i've never
seen any of this i have pictures in
college
i didn't oh i didn't know you did yeah
yeah y'all don't believe me i really
went to college
i'm not doubting you went to college
yeah wait okay what you're definitely
in college i'd like to i just i want
some proof all right
i'm ready to bring pictures of me and
college i know now we gotta we gotta
[ __ ] preach
i'll bring it up you don't have them
online nah
probably on facebook but i'm not about
to go through that now yeah right yeah
bring him in
bring him in i do i mean i would love to
see it exactly what was your favorite
subject
you know communications interesting
i just stopped buying it man and that's
fine i've never heard anyone say that
[Laughter]
you know talking was my favorite subject
i just love to communicate
so i mentioned communications
you know i just like to talk to people
in the world so i was like
oh communication that's my lane that's
my lane
communications with every was every
athlete's page
exactly it was the easiest one to get
easy one that wasn't yours
no no i was uh business sociology your
business
uh mine's communications it related to
me yeah
cat kitty cats coming to miami with us
miami you've never been before i've
never been stevie's old stomping grounds
yep his old stomping grounds back when
he used to look like a guido
oh you've seen him in his like miami
days no oh it's from unrecognized do you
have like the pauly d
here yeah and he has a ferrari and he
has some thin ass eyebrows he doesn't
look like the same person
really you wouldn't be friends with him
because he looked like the biggest tool
yeah but those were the days
like that was the thing that was the
thing that was when jersey shore was
popping
does he look like ronnie from jersey
situations like blonde cousin he looks
like the situation
security he was like jacked and weird
eyebrows
security guard yeah what does he need
security
same height steve is an interesting case
because stevie's a kid who
uh if anyone should have mental illness
that's what i was talking about when
we're chilling the cabin over coffee
if anyone should have mental illness
should be stevie yeah
shitty parents dude shitty people i
don't know that she's
not made me saying this shitty parents
had straight up
cancer at 17 at 17 year old with cancer
before that got ran over broke both his
legs
ran over by a car how about he was in a
wheelchair yeah all right he's in a
wheelchair
force gum style even wheelchair
lieutenant dan
lieutenant you got new legs
and then [ __ ] gets cancer at 17
his mom would just drop him off or she
wouldn't drop him off at all
to get chemo and then he was a 17 year
old in the grown-ups hospital not the
child
hospital look at him there it's such a
shame
he does look like a jersey shore uh cast
member
dude who would you like that kid god you
could just tell by the key chain he was
the [ __ ] wallet chain yeah hell yeah
cargo shirts but you think it's stevie
so
gets dropped off for chemotherapy he's
there with all people who are basically
dying
like everyone has cancer you know chemo
you gotta be the first he said eight
hours a day
his parents would be like dude where's
the doctor like where the [ __ ] your
parents like
i don't know so he's there by himself at
17 facing cancer
then to get the reasoning out the homer
tattoo we make fun of him but the reason
he got the homework tattoo
is he'd watch simpsons on an ipad
because that's right yeah
like you couldn't talk to these old
people so you just watched simpsons all
the time
i was like how are you normal now stevie
normally
i mean i think when you go through some
[ __ ] like that you just find peace
because you're like
or not or not or or you find yourself in
a water tower you went to prison too
and yeah you know went to prison but
also this how loyal stevie is why i [ __ ]
with stevie when my house was broken
into
with people with guns well i had to
leave to go on tour to australia
stevie does never met my girl before and
tiger was four months old
stevie came over and while we me and
chill were in australia for two weeks
slept on my couch every night i didn't
ask him to do that really yep
with the gap yeah yep ready ready come
on back y'all come on back come on come
get some come on
come on blue eyes waiting for you yeah
damn that's crazy my game know my girl
would just show that okay how's it going
like it was a job
yeah he is a pretty peaceful guy you
don't really see him get like [ __ ]
you know ever he's just very chill yeah
yeah i think i mean it's just
certain people that go through [ __ ] once
they find that piece
i like when people talk about going to
prison and he's like man that guy didn't
do no [ __ ]
oh yeah he can always tell like he
didn't do [ __ ] yeah
i guess you could probably tell by the
way they talk yeah have you been through
it you know
like what's eating for you like
smuggling drugs i noticed like hanging
around people who've been to prison they
the last thing they want to talk about
is prison they never have like they're
like man i want to talk about that
because there's like bro he's so much
it's like bro
i wasted all my life away yeah you know
what yeah actually yeah
my dad i mean he'll talk about it with
me yeah it's just i mean
i think it's just for us like it's
something to talk about he just he's
like yeah yeah yeah of course he's
coming
this is where i was at exactly it's what
he like expresses
you know what i mean i think with stevie
you know
she'll talk about it he'll talk about it
but he's not i'll tell you what stevia
celia on going to prison
it doesn't sound that bad you got
playstation xbox okay we're talking
about this
yeah what was he saying he was saying
how he's like dude it wasn't terrible
for me at the federal prison like i was
with my homies every day
he's like if you could just have girls
in there like i would have stayed uh-huh
he's like no boundless you can't talk to
any girls or nothing so you're just with
the boys but
if you have good friends like we would
eat together hang out talk and sleep
wake up was that miami pick uh
pre-prison
yes pre-prison that was him at like 21.
i wonder if he knows the jersey shore
cast no he has a picture of him in the
situation i think he ran into him at a
club but like i don't think he knows
he looks just like who's situation
he looks so ridiculous gtl gtl bro you
jersey shore fan yeah still gtl to this
day yeah
that's his name he looks so much better
now his face like looks he wants to go
tanning soon for miami actually
he does oh he still goes every now and
then if he's going somewhere where it's
going to be hot he wants to pre-tan so
he doesn't burn when he gets there i
guess that's something like tv
dude man oh he's great-looking like
we're on the road i mean girls are like
jesus christ
stevie blue eyes stevie put some respect
i look like [ __ ]
knows i'm always like dude get over
there go far less
yeah get away from me why are you
standing there don't look like shrek
get over there you're [ __ ] pretty ass
i see him in the mirror sometimes he'll
just comb his beard yeah
and then britney looking he's growing
his hair yeah just like you and she
yeah i was like what'd you do with your
hair man and now i have all the products
he has
yeah what are you going to do with your
hair let's go a little bit growing it
yeah let it grow out
get some cornrows ooh that'd be dope
what'd you do this weekend chen
oh i was going to stevie real quick what
would you say you did this weekend
[Laughter]
e-bike riding again a bike ride they're
all here i love it now
they're just too easy though i know so
we we put on zero
pedal assist and then [ __ ] just when
it's like really hard we'll put on some
pedal assist
mostly just how far do you guys go i
think we were like we went on a 45
minute ride
down a trail down oh you were going down
to a trail
what was this [ __ ] we wrote in uh utah
that wasn't e-bike
no hell no that wasn't an e-bike i bust
my ass wait so
what e-bikes easier to control or
something hey go go back to the first
picture
that's a dope picture by the way are you
gonna leave me out of it
blazing through smoking with my big road
jay
[Applause]
look how serious and focused stevie look
at why y'all like
brendon he labeled you as in the squad
that's malik's jacket by the way that's
all he can how did he fit in that
yeah how do you fit in that because me
and jay are the same size
you are not
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what they call that dream is uh uh
demons on your chest
when you're paralyzed when you're
paralyzed right yeah go to stevie
playing the guitar the [ __ ] can
rip man oh yeah he can
has he played live for you oh yeah he
plays every single morning
[Music]
[Applause]
i think that tone is great um jamming
huh you guys ever jammed together
we haven't because you can play the
guitar too
yeah but i don't know yeah i don't know
why we never like
officially maybe wanted some guitars and
jam out man
i think he gets sad when he sees you
playing guitar with chin in the studio
oh nobody invites me i'm sorry we should
probably have stevie on the show
i don't know some people know who the
[ __ ] he is stevie they know they know
but i get a better idea same with justin
too justin is almost like a
fighter in the kid's urban legend he's
the urban legend yeah
another reading world look at the reason
i get that the reading world
get the squad over here because him and
malik do a podcast together
and people always talk [ __ ] to him not
talk [ __ ] to him but like
they like to like say mainly his looks
yeah oh they make fun of his look we do
that here
pretty much like the way you just did
sandy look like the
oh they killed them yeah they said
someone said he looked like franklin the
turtle
franklin the turtle he just has like a
purple
round head they just roast them on
they said
hey frankly
that's franklin the turtleman
it just rose justin man hey what's the
caption on his ig there on the phone
always asking when the money he said
answer the calls because it might be the
chat
hashtag motivation get better hashtag
won't stop
i love his captions it's nothing but rap
lyrics it's nothing but
rattlers
what's up kids let's take a little break
from the squad because ufc 260 is this
freaking saturday stipe francis the
rematch we've all been waiting for
for the heavyweight championship you
gotta watch the fights
and make money with draftking sportsbook
the official
sports betting partner of the ufc it's
putting you in the center of the action
with a special odds boost for all the
final kid listeners
so here's a parlay i personally pick
just for you guys he can make
bank bro vicente luke sean o'malley and
francis dengano
if they all win their fights you make
money all right
just head to the app now find brendan
jobs picks under the odds boost tab
you'll see it there my name's there
doesn't matter if you're new or existing
customer bet on it get your
boosted odds and ride along with your
thick boy here
plus don't forget there will be tons of
college basketball it's march madness
of course so all new users download the
top rated draftking sportsbook
now use the promo code fighter when you
sign up bet on my parlay
of fighters to win saturday night for
ufc 260
again to get the parlay to boost the
odds you got to bet on vint
vincent vicente luke sean o'malley and
francine gano
if all three win you make bank all right
that's this saturday ufc 260 take
advantage of my special odds parlay
boost
that's promo code fighter only at
draftking sportsbook
must be 21 and older new jersey
pennsylvania indiana michigan or
virginia only restrictions apply see
draftkings.com
for full details gambling problem call
1-800 gambler
or in indiana 1-809 with it or in
virginia
five three two thirty five hundred again
that's draftking sportsbook
promo code fighter bet on my parlay luke
a
o'malley franciscano you're welcome
uh that's fine oh this was [ __ ] yeah so
uh
you know how much [ __ ] trump would get
if you would have done this like
trump's missed a step and like stumbled
and comes up and obviously
beats it up the stairs and it was like
news all over
now with biden like obviously people are
making fun of him but cnn ain't running
those stories on this they
you have you seen this no i haven't seen
it i saw him dude he's such a fragile
old man he's 81 right he is i think 78
but like close to 80. damn yeah yeah he
was stumbling on his way up
uh air force one and you couldn't get up
the first time the second time or the
third time you finally got up i'm trying
to procrastinate
oh my god did you see what putin said
roast
because he called putin a killer i'll
tell you after this
oprah phil yeah on the step bust their
ass the keys off
uh you know he called putin a killer
yeah putin said takes one to no one
and then putin goes hey man if you wanna
have a debate we can have a discussion
because you know he can't really speak
yeah so boone's like yeah if you want to
have open dialogue let's do it bubba
there's silence on the other end yeah
everyone's like
america's like we don't want him talking
and and let's let the records show he's
only president
he hasn't had a press conference not yet
not yet
he's like the first one yet yeah and a
hundred it's been like a hundred days
he struggles yeah speaking to him which
is a problem for the leader of the
freeway
yeah gotta go to my communication class
man so
uh deshawn watson has 13 lawsuits
alleging sexual misconduct after
more women came forward massage
therapist yeah they're all massages
trying to get a happy ending
i like it when he would he would call
them to his hou this is what the
the report report is he would call him
to the house
and then they would like set up the
table would come out naked and they'd be
like can you put on some
pants or undies like i get hot
but i know a lot of people that get
massages naked that's just what they do
you know
but it sounds like you keep flipping
over and just like dick would be like
dude also you're the starting
quarterback for the houston texans
why are you harassing these massage
therapists like dude you could
just send out a dm like lonely who wants
netflix and chill
and you get 10 of the baddest [ __ ]
yeah in houston texas coming through
like you could have magnus down like
what are you doing in houston
so all of this is with massage it's
about massage
there's some other ones that came out
now i think the other first few were
massage therapists and then the other
women were
i don't think they had any affiliation
with like uh
going to his house and being employed
12 women and there's 10 others they're
talking to
so there's so it's not good that'd be
22. here's my thing
let's say half of them are just making
[ __ ] up
you're still at 11 bucks yeah you're
still 11.
let's say 90 are making it up you still
got a few cases on your hand
it's just interesting right because he's
holding out with the houston texans
and he's like all right fine i'm not
going to play and then where the
conspiracy comes from is this
lawyer lives in the same neighborhood as
the owner so the lord came out i was
like i know people are speculating like
the this the houston texans [ __ ] on
uh
desean watson because i know he was i've
never met the owner i wouldn't know what
he looked like
i saw him and he's basically saying
we're both rich [ __ ] so we live in this
specific neighborhood in houston but i
don't know the [ __ ] guy we're just
both rich white guys and we live in the
same neighborhood
he's like but i don't know him at any
facet and the problem is this lawyer is
not like a hype beast he's like a
legitimate
jail lawyer i got a question for you
because you was in the middle of
um i was in the league as much as anyone
in here was in the league but yeah
okay okay so years we had a debate you
said he's not gonna
like play the 2021 season not a chance
not
in 2021 there's no way but he didn't
want to play for the texans
now he has no choice all right so when
will we see
deshaun watson and if you had to guess
like let's say it depends what else
comes out
it depends like it depends where this
court goes because they're pressing
charges now
so they are yeah i think so it's a
lawsuit
oh yeah the six woman claims that watson
grabbed his genitals tried to force her
to perform oral sex during separate
instances in june
uh august last year do you know
the allegations in the sixth see this
during the pandemic
and the six lawsuits filed monday
largely after that those have been
detailed in remainder of litigation five
of the women alleged that watson exposed
himself
to them during a massage um
four of those women also claimed he
touched him with his genitals during the
the incident he can't touch them with
his i don't get it dude
deshawn you're one top five quarterback
in the league good looking dude
yeah 125 million dollar contract 20 mil
in the bank why
are you harassing these women
in houston there's so many baddies in
houston
what send a tweet out looking for a
massage man
i just showed up what about what dude
you never heard of rub
maps what's that it's a site we can go
to where
it shows you places with happy endings
how do you know that
i'm on the street you've been on the
streets in a long time
how the hell you know what streets
you've been on right now
now where is this dirty streets they're
even [ __ ] with massages you don't
[ __ ] but you [ __ ] with happy indians i
don't like being touched like get up off
me
oh yeah a lot of people that's like jay
he won't do i love him
i love him but some you know that you
know i i don't know what happened
if he's forcing girls do stuff like
that's a problem dude yeah
100 percent care about that you think he
plays i think so
you think he's playing 20 21 even with
with all that because
the problem is is like now society's so
woke the nfl would look so
bad if they let him play even though
he's so talented but [ __ ] dude
let me i'm gonna let you finish and i
got a counter for you yeah you're saying
he wanted to sit out
yeah so but he'll not no you know you
[ __ ] up right because the problem now
is
he wanted to sit out so if you're the
houston jackson jack right he's not
gonna play
let's see if he'll really sit out and
sit out this year but now his worth
ain't [ __ ] okay so he has to go to the
patriots
no yeah the patriots pick him up now
he's not getting hate anymore now we
know you
you tell me countless of times instagram
social media everything is not real
correct
okay cool underneath this wall is though
the law is carrying all right so the
lowest 22 women
are though okay okay the lawyer and
everyone is represented by that lawyer
this lawyer
and pastor has passed allegations that
he had a billboard
like in the past and get desean out of
houston so he already
hates this he doesn't like him he
doesn't at all that doesn't matter
here's the problem
not only does he not like him but now he
has a reason to get him out of houston
and now and that and here's the problem
if he was like some terrible lawyer but
all right good luck with that
you're not my legit bulldog lawyer like
he's legitimately good
it'd be like johnny wow he'd be like
johnny cochran taking on these women be
like oh [ __ ] you screwed
but why not why why now though i don't
either i i'm not a big conspiracy guy
but
i don't know i don't know is it because
he said maybe because he's sitting out
and he's being difficult and people
fuse they're like what the [ __ ] these
women are like oh really dude you you
you want to sit out and you just sign a
100 million dollar contract
all right and then they come like
something pissed these women off
that's insane you see yeah it is insane
but i don't think the lawyer is calling
women i'd be like hey do you know
deshawn do you have any problems
i don't think 22 is a lot it's got to be
summoned yeah
that's i mean that's a lot and this this
lawyer is like he's making a point
get he's not trying to get him out of
houston he's basically trying to ruin
deshawn
yeah a hundred mill he you know he
hasn't so that lawyer didn't like him at
all
he didn't want to get this shot now
deshaun is put like i'm not playing at
all then he comes out
and then there's a report that the owner
of houston texas now again i heard what
the lawyer said
but you don't see you don't think they
know each other like hey you know
he said he says he doesn't he's like i
have no he's like you can look it up i
have no interaction with the guy he's
like if that guy was in a lineup i
couldn't pick him out he's like i don't
know who he is
no i don't know if who knows yeah i'm
with you yeah yeah it's very
strange my problem 22 22.
so let's say 18 of them are lying
just the four if they're telling the
truth you're still back i still back
yeah
four dude even if one out of the 22 is
telling the truth he's [ __ ]
he has 20 especially in 2021 dude this
is different time like
just allegations looking at my friends i
know
there's not even lawsuits against them
doug they're [ __ ]
deshawn watson in 2021 what team's gonna
sign like
especially with the media like dude
they're gonna go come from
his for his head whatever so what team
wants that negative pr now
the patriots i don't know do you think
so i don't know not
in 2021 it's [ __ ] tough man but dan
so he
got i mean yeah i don't know what
happened that this is so weird that's
all
houston texas are super [ __ ] because
you get you paid them all that money
all that money hundred million you give
him all that money and he gets that
money i see jay thinks he does i don't
think he i don't
well i think i'm with you it's somewhere
in that contract they're to take his
money i guarantee it
like i know he's getting all that money
but you can't but he but he already said
they already gave him some upfront well
he got it like they took money back from
uh aaron hernandez
you killed two people give us our
[ __ ] money back but he didn't use you
the nflpa what jay was
not was disgusting exactly the vic case
so now
you he had that guarantee you can't go
back and forth you can't take it back
there's no way you can in the con listen
the lawyers in the nfl who represent nfl
in the houston texans are so [ __ ]
smart
there's no way you can get accused of 22
sexual assault cases
and still get full pension there's no
way
to [ __ ] wait so they took vick's money
after when he went to jail when he went
to jail
and rightfully so dude rightfully so you
killed
[ __ ] hundreds of dogs we can't market
you dude we can't sell your jerseys
you completely [ __ ] the program over
why would we continue to pay the same
salary
yeah and i agree with you it's like
obviously this is never going to happen
but let's say
chin gets accused of 22 sexual assaults
i'm just saying this is my example let's
say hypothetically he gets accused of 22
sexual assaults
chin's values [ __ ] dude he you ruined
the show i can't get to your patreon the
same salary
but we know that that's why we know that
the sports is more lenient
to towards uh the nfl pa they used to be
not we're in a different time now yeah
but there's people have been [ __ ] up
for way less
yeah but i have friends who've been
[ __ ] over way less i know but okay
okay
let's see what happens with the lawsuit
though that see that that's that's the
thing once it goes to court yeah he
hasn't
and then who knows what evidence they
have we don't know we do know they have
texts
of desean watson like hey sorry i made
you feel uncomfortable
huh have you ever texted a therapist
that message
sorry it made you feel uncomfortable why
would you send that yeah
damn it i didn't know that that is weird
i didn't i didn't know about that that's
what the lawyer seems like we have
attacks of him after the massage
therapist left
like hey sorry i got too aggressive did
that leak oh that's out yeah
they posted that like you said about it
so i i don't know
i didn't know that i'm trying to it's
awful but i just think in 2021
even with the contract i know there's
the vic rule but
and let the record show i'm not
defending if he did these things i'm not
defending
no but there are some there are some
there's some questions yeah
let's get him you know i mean 20. see
that that's what's scary is that lawyer
because let's get him and it's a legit
bulldog lawyer it's not like this hype
lawyer like it's something
[ __ ] yeah low level lawyer this guy has
worked major cases correct so he's like
let's get him he's been
yeah and you release the hounds man
that's trouble really houston texas
yeah there's so there's so many
questions yeah i mean
like yeah how did he get in i said this
i don't know what
happened yeah i have no [ __ ] clue
offending deshaun i'm to defend those
women
i have no clue mm-hmm you don't know
there have been a little that came out
and they're full of [ __ ]
so who knows yeah and then there's also
really bad guys out there i don't know
what happened
yeah but didn't you just say to yourself
if you're deshawn watson what are you
just what just take bro why don't you
leave it up to that thank you
yeah you have your boys he's a good
looking dude he's a great looking he you
did you see his girlfriend she's bad
you don't need bro you have one of your
boys like hey man deshawn
horny can you come and then you don't
have to go through that like deshawn
just put a
ig story i said hey look at that oh and
then she had to turn her
her name is j j uh jillian that's a girl
she had to turn her comments off because
everyone's my god
that's his girl for the last couple of
years and now schneiderlin she's a smoke
show she turned her comments off because
uh
everyone was just rushing over
bombarding her with negativity that girl
didn't have anything to do with that but
again
you know dude she is a 10. oh yeah man
more than the 10.
again quarterbacks in the league yeah
that's crazy man yeah it's
it's a shame man that's crazy what else
you got jen
god damn [ __ ] smoke show
okay uh have you seen anything about
this the ncaa
apologized recently because a tick tock
went viral
of i believe she plays on the oregon
women's basketball
team and she recorded what
the girl's weight lifting room looked
like versus the guys weightlifting room
and it started a lot of controversy
because on one hand
there were people like steph curry who
called out the ncaa saying that
it's wrong it's unequal and then there's
people like swaggy p
nikki young coming out saying well
you're the jv league like you don't
bring in the type of money that
the boys say i got hats
hackers swag
and then um ncaa came out and said that
they apologized for what happened
and that the girls didn't have space
yeah in their facility to
hold that type of equipment she made an
updated tick tock saying
we have more than enough space this is
stupid oh she
lied no no no no so for the ncaa march
madness the biggest tournament
in college basketball for women this is
our weight room
let me show you all the men's weight
room
that looks pretty sick now our weight
room got released versus the men's the
ncaa came out with a statement saying
that it wasn't money
it was space that was a problem let me
show y'all something else
here's our practice court right and then
here's that weight room
and then this extra
space if you are upset about this
problem then you're a part of it
i got something i got a question here's
where it gets dicey
do me a favor how many people watch
women's march madness last year
well that shouldn't mean they shouldn't
have gym like a dope gym oh hold on hold
on
let's hold on it's easy to say
how are they gonna have the same dope
gym let's say you're running the ncaa
okay you're on the ncaa well there was
no march madness last year due 2019
viewership
2000 oh so but there was no men's right
2019 there it is
i think a big issue with this i saw
somebody talk about this on twitter
in the ncaa rules men and women
regardless of how much money they bring
in
have to have the same yeah that's
unrealistic hey so go
so 7.3 million now go to the men's how
many people watch the men's march
madness oh i know
i'm in there the title game is the 2019
sure ten point nine other was three
mm-hmm not seven seven seven so it's not
that much
the problem is to be fair uh somebody
released a statistic of how much it
costs
to fund the women's team every single
year and it was a few million versus how
much they brought in
it barely it was a fraction of what they
actually bring in whereas the men's
was very profitable so you do have a
point there where like yeah every time
you run the business it's like it's not
that it shouldn't be equal they should
definitely have a weight room like
obviously nc double a [ __ ]
yeah but if i'm running a business so
you know if i'm running a business let's
say
let's say my business was based off
instagram followers that's
cat and chin and cat has ten thousand
followers and chin has a million
and i'm a business and i'm running ads
and chins bring in
a hun a million dollars a month okay and
cats bring in ten thousand dollars a
month
and cat goes i want a car chin goes i
want a car
i'll probably give chin a better car
because he's bringing in money so
it makes sense to give chin the better
car opposed to cat even though she's a
woman
it's not a fact that she's a woman he's
a man it's a fact that
he brings in 100 you're going off no she
brings in yeah
but we make it this this you know sex
thing you know women deserve this
and it's like i'm not even saying that
same with like wnba
you're mad how many people watch how
many people watch your game
now that is is that a is that whose
problem is that
what why do people prefer to watch men's
mba than women's wnb
uh because then well again i hate the
the knack that they say women's women's
basketball is more skilled
but it's some skill control exactly but
you that's the narrative they put out
there
but again men's basketball is
entertaining but but again
if i'm a business that me brings in how
many viewers
where's the women what does the w nba
bring in
their biggest games are the finals so if
you go wa uh but they're all 2019
finals but their finals are not fair
because they're on their finals are the
same
time that the nba finals are on no
there's there's a uh later no it's a
little bit there's
nothing like there's after there's after
yeah like september
i don't know so allergens 750 000
viewers
i'm sorry 570 000. okay now go the
uh the men's nba 220 finals
8.8 million uh it says 15
50 million average was 80 million the
high was 15. so the women's high was
what
500. 570 000. men's was 15 million
[Music]
what do you want i mean what do you want
to do dude advertisers pay whoever
those advertisers don't give a [ __ ] if
it's man or woman they just want the
eyeballs so they have tires not going oh
yeah because they're women we don't want
to work with them they go no
we want to be in front of 15 million
people yeah so it's tough
now granted ncaa [ __ ] up those women
should have a proper facility
like that's right that's that's all i'm
saying i'm like why can't they just like
now
at least the problem should be the same
facility as the men yeah
somebody's saying but i can't have a
collab a joint like when it was just at
least
something better i shouldn't just have
those dumbbells yeah that's just
insulting
yeah they got those dumbbells from the
liquid because if i had a daughter i'd
be [ __ ]
furious yeah like i like like i'm not
talking about like the viewership or
anything like that
i'm just saying like a [ __ ] weight
facility
that is at least like you know proper
and accommodating and better
see this this is what's weird it goes
from what i've been showing the pairs of
swag bags where the men receive
are much more substantial than the
women's as well
again more there's more revenue there's
more ads so they have the the
ability to put up the money for that
yeah so it's not a man or woman thing
it's a money thing
i know i know a couple of ways so what
so basically the ncaa has this budget
they're like okay here's our budget for
this and that's how they map it out yep
i know a couple of ways that that can
get viewers to watch the denver nba
wmeb easy now tread lightly bubble okay
what'd you say i know a couple of ways a
lot of people
say lower the rim and all that but lower
the rim you know
so what is it what is their rim it's the
same as means
it has to be oh it's ten feet yeah lower
the
yeah you lower the rim you're gonna have
more fights it's gonna be entertaining
there's no more layups that that gym
that women's job
is insulting it isn't just four
dumbbells like nah you got this
bro they're gonna kill those dogs get
creative ladies yeah get creative come
on ncaa
at least at least try a little that's
what i know they don't bring
the same money but jesus christ man the
highest exactly
but that was that's legit they're what
they gave them yeah that's ridiculous
that's what i'm saying i'm like you
could do better yeah
a little bit way better than be a little
less obvious than that and 12 yoga mats
like this will stay like that and please
like that listen i understand viewership
stats blah blah blah yeah yeah you know
give a girl a medicine ball
or at least let them like because here's
the other here's the other argument too
it's like
you know those universities make so much
[ __ ] money whether it's men or women
they make
so much money you could give them a
better job yeah i mean
like you know being cheerleaders we were
allowed to use you know
something funny no dude no what are you
doing
what you were saying what's your
statement i'm sorry i was laughing at
that you know lord of the rings i was
laughing at that
go ahead bro your cheerleaders you did
you guys get equal rights
do you guys have to drink from a
separate fountain how does that work
with cheerleaders
they gave you weighted pom-poms no he
was like like we would use the same
[ __ ] but it was
it was after they were done last night
that is not what the hell i'm saying
what i'm saying is like like we would
get their gatorade if they were finished
with it
i love like 87
facilities for cheerleaders at certain
colleges are dope as [ __ ] like big time
uh oklahoma state the cowboys boo-boo
yeah kansas too yeah yeah
texas tech they have gopass facilities i
go to the games just to watch they make
so much money they could definitely
apply that's what i'm saying why
couldn't they even do that dude
ncaa is the biggest [ __ ] scam in the
world you wanna talk about a corrupt
business model brother
talk kids over there nice they don't
have nothing they pay them nothing
nothing
and take all the money all the money and
then they go oh we're doing education
do you think athletes should be paid 100
yes tim tebow when he's playing had the
number one selling jersey over lebron
james you know what he made for that
zero and then he went all to florida
wait when he was in college yes
he was that famous definitely you know
how much money he got zero
florida new jersey florida took all the
money that had his name
yeah this was his right hand i know yeah
i know i know his thing okay yeah
really yeah bro let's talk about it ncaa
video games
he had his face on the cover had the
video games yeah they don't get money
from that
ask them how much but now they there's a
license deal where they give them some
percentage but
not a lot but it's a slap it's not right
yeah because they keep because their
thing is
because they really have free calls yeah
they're like you got a free education
like [ __ ] you made me major in
communications i can't use this
yeah yeah he's using it i'm using it
you're communicating
exactly it's it's all [ __ ] up i mean
i know it's like super effective yeah
like when oklahoma or ohio state goes to
a bowl game
okay they get like 40 million dollars
and i'm like we're giving these kids
40 minutes to school the school it goes
back to now yeah
so if a team that why do you think
college was like
frantic about figuring out how to play
during covet because they make
so much so much [ __ ] football off
football
and he's corrupt that's why the pac-12s
[ __ ] it's mostly because they were
[ __ ] because they were the only ones
that didn't want to play i wasn't
playing yeah so everyone's transferring
and now they don't have money
so they're cutting stamford wrestling
even though they have a national
champion
like they don't have money because these
[ __ ] morons were the only conference
that
i didn't know it was like that it's the
most corrupt business bond in the world
yeah damn and they have women's
basketball
in the store i want it clear those women
should have a better course that's you
they should have if i'm a businessman
i'm like all right let's let's
take out don't don't do better than that
don't don't get wrong this should be
better than that but
the same thing if i'm a owner of the nba
team wnba team and i'm going through
taxes
and i don't know men or women i'm like
what the [ __ ] going on here
well i don't want to be part of that no
don't give them a two million dollar
locker room you know yeah
and someone's like oh those are women
like i don't care all i care about is my
bottom dollar
that's how that's what they're thinking
got it and if i was a businessman i'd
say lower the rim i'm tired of watching
skillful layups
get dunked on sorry brenda no i'm with
you
what else you got it is
currently spring break season so i
believe
last weekend uh it was mayhem in florida
specifically south beach
and it was so bad to the point where the
mayor of
miami had to come out and say that
there's going to be a curfew this
upcoming week for south beach
where it this morning shuts down yeah
this upcoming week
starting from saturday for at least 72
hours there's going to be a 8 p.m curfew
but it's only it's
going to affect my shows because miami
improv is not in south beach yeah it's
not on south beach so you're fine
it's just getting to and from this area
is going to be tricky after 8 pm
damn they live and i was just about to
say that i understand
but
uh the car you see that video where the
fellas i'm just spit up spitballing
ideas here
i don't see a lot of white people
because you can just tell cause
they're about to swag surf you know
they're they're lit yeah pretty black
i've never been in miami it's a
metropolitan
area it's pretty dumb latin why is
white people go to miami tea for spring
break yeah but spring break for black
people is like freak knicks you ever
heard of that
a freak it's a freak [ __ ] what's that
you don't know about free nick no
oh bro you heard
so we don't want to stay you guys are
staying south beach mm-hmm we're saying
southeastern it's a bad idea so
we're supposed to i wonder if we should
get out of there because it'd be a
nightmare getting out of there and
everything's being shut down
we won't be able to do anything it is
primarily well as long as you uh
go out in miami and stay away from that
south beach area you're going to be fine
because it's just south beach
south beach is not big it's like you're
saying south beach there's nothing to do
exactly so as long as you go out to the
other parts of miami you're fine
what's the other parts of miami besides
south beach southeast by far the biggest
yeah that's what i'm saying so you can't
be on opa-locka
talking about mcdonald's
[Applause]
no wait no can't wait
because i don't know what it was it's a
street in miami
oh there you go
[Applause]
thank you like i don't know my stomach i
wasn't doubting you on opa-locka that's
sounds like we might want to get an
airbnb outside south beach though
yeah i gotta probably steal too man i
gotta dope out sweets
makes sense though because no one's
there like you can stay here
yeah sure before this is before yeah we
just got announced uh yesterday
yeah we're gonna pass on that you don't
want to be down there and not be able to
get out and [ __ ]
so what you're gonna do i mean uh cat i
don't know we're gonna figure it out
i booked everything already so i'm sure
you i'm sure you'll be like due to
lockdowns i need my [ __ ] money back
that's what i'm gonna do yeah yeah and
we can just say that yeah and save your
money and go in the
airbnb with us we'll just get a dope
airbnb oh google says he can't lock down
airbnbs
oh that's you steve you don't want to
stay with us hmm i never said that you
want to say an opal
i was saying
he's like man hey
i've never been to miami i wouldn't know
i'm not gonna open
[Applause]
what y'all going to do besides south
beach stay in opa-locka no i thought you
said
cut open lockers which i
don't want to take part in because
security is heavy
oh yeah they think out there dude what
is up with these [ __ ] parents yeah
doing this [ __ ] it'd be tough for me not
to fight him if i was there oh right
like are you [ __ ] up right yeah you so
a father
and his child went to the san diego zoo
just a day out together as a family and
what he decided to do
was to take his son a young child like
he's basically
he's like a kid kid like tiger kid he
took his child snuck through the
barriers of the elephant exhibit
got inside to see an elephant as
they were walking in kind of looking
around an elephant
uh i saw the video i haven't seen let me
see the video i don't think this one has
the race video huh can we guess the
right i love this game go ahead
i actually don't know i don't know
either here i'll send you the video
channel it's all over chin yeah
you don't need to send it oh you got it
i think bar stool has it
but basically what happens is an
elephant sees them starts
charging at them and they get out there
just in time but they they say the
elephant knew it was a kid so that's why
he didn't oh
oh
like what the [ __ ] like why
he drops his kid as he's trying to run
through
that little barrier
everyone's making fun of him he is a 25
year old father doing this
what uh what's his name guy
um james said the elephant was not
harmed
can they release that uh andrew james no
that's the spokesman okay
yes can they release his info or no
oh the kid is even younger than i
thought the kid was two yeah
[ __ ] play stupid games win stupid prizes
we were watching this weekend about like
i don't know why but like
bad accidents and what was that country
when they sent us you or they s
elephants stump on you to death you know
oh yeah we were we watching that yeah
is it thailand thailand there's some
place where
there's stuff like it i used to be like
an executioner execution
they would let the elephants yeah so do
you understand
you jumping into the elephant's cages
for a selfie
i don't know i i really don't know
[ __ ] it was a black guy
it was i'm pretty sure it was black guy
why because his name was james
his name's not james the zoo uh guy's
name oh names
just in the picture it looked like a
black guy okay let's see
i think i heard him say open locker
there it is
oh let's see what he looks like
jose okay that's what he looks like
he got arrested i was gonna say mexican
jose is definitely mexican
bruh ain't no black people jumping into
him we don't we don't care about that we
don't
hell no no usually to be fair it's
usually a white person
you know what black people call a lot of
asians fall off cliffs
taking selfies yes that is they just
like get the selfie stick and they're
like
two fingers no they just
fall off the mountain because we love
photos
we love selfies they die all the time we
will die for a selfie asia's out here
dying
off a mountain yeah that's usually asian
that dies with selfies
yeah it's you anything like photo
related is usually asian i feel like
then usually animals is white white
people love
i love animals he don't like birds
without without a kid would you sneak
into an exhibit today never never
great why would you i don't want to be
around that over there
i mean i'd like to squeeze his trunk but
whatever what is it with you and animal
noses
[Laughter]
oh yeah this is my [ __ ] right here they
tagged me it's a pill
yeah that big boy flipped over bruh
says can any other 265 pounder do this
flip yep
yeah i got a friend who's 276. get the
[ __ ]
out of here no no when you started but
you're still doing flips
yeah yeah you're doing 276 what that guy
do baby
what that guy do baby 276 you're doing a
flip hard
yeah that [ __ ] is a wrestler but
you you want to you won the national you
know what um
wrestlers uh super athletic super
athletic
wrestlers were like the easiest to like
teach when it came to
background clearly it's [ __ ] hard man
they were like
they were like no do backflips you could
do it you can i can teach you in a
heartbeat oh i'd love that
you taught ben and i would do it on
stage
i can do it too so no you do it i'm like
man what you doing
oh yeah both flip at the same time i can
literally teach anyone to do a [ __ ]
bag
literally i don't wanna break my i'm
older i don't want to get hurt my neck
no i get it
you're happy but it's literally the
easiest [ __ ] thing well you said once
you see your feet
is is automatically you never know what
yeah just watch your feet and you know i
feel
good teach me how to backflip man do you
really want to learn yeah
that'd be sick i'll spot you yeah it's
easy yeah yeah don't you like help them
like go like that yeah just give them a
bumper though you could do that guys on
stage
i don't want to fall you want me to spot
you yeah i'd be sick you just gotta
commit
because you're a big boy you're a big
boy
what are you busting out just fall like
that oh my god [ __ ] it
that show was lit yeah like man brady
driving back
later that weekend when you guys have
all your like stage photos just you on
the flight of [ __ ]
that's my time guys
somebody get the reading worm out here
does he have a hot 30.
we can't fire the re-worm he on the
opa-locka
quick tell everybody to tell steve you
get his big dick
distract me roll off
the funniest part is
that's the main attraction
[ __ ] horrible oh that [ __ ] sounds
funny have you guys seen
mike bibby yeah yeah he's shredded yeah
he look like me
that's very suddenly a sun surprise to
me though
he's always been this disrespectful yeah
[ __ ] you know gabrielle i didn't know he
actually posted about it yeah that's
insane
did you see the video of him uh chucking
uh mike baby uh
shoes during the game dwyane wade uh-uh
oh it was funny that's why that's why
she kind of
she said hey dwayne wade i bet you
wouldn't chuck baby shoe now look at
this
bag i'm like what the [ __ ]
baby it was a baller too yeah i love him
he's from arizona
is that that was right he's a kid and
then him and miles simon right
yep he was dope that boy on trt is that
his son to the
yeah next to him i think he's just
someone he shoots uh with maybe
he he he does has like a wax figure he
looks fake
that boy's jacked it was a shame that
him and chris webber could not
get over there you know you know where i
met him i met him and gary payton at a
carry-on show i met gary payton at a
boxing match he's so
he's dude he's so nice yo he's so funny
so nice he's such a beast
yes the glove the glove what did jordan
say
oh he said uh jordan was like man he
started laughing when he was like if i
just
guarded mike the first three games i
guarantee you've been a different series
glove nike shoe oh it's so dope it's
like a
there there
right there the second one yeah those
black ones you get did you have a seat
right here yeah i had a pair i couldn't
you know
you could on diploma did pippin have
shoes yeah yeah shoes was it for her
it's pretty dope
i mean i didn't ever work no one really
[ __ ] with [ __ ] i wanted these by
having a money while i was going i had
me and jay ball so people [ __ ] with
the [ __ ]
iversons jordans obviously kobe's we had
coach kobe's
shawn kips strawberries the jason kids
the [ __ ] uh
jason kids were dope you didn't [ __ ]
with the strawberries i hated this stuff
the strawberries were terrible you love
starbursts i don't know
everybody the end ones those were big
ones those are big yeah
those were he had some weird ones get
some weird ones there's the shacks
yeah shacks shaq made good money off
those shoes though
right steve franchise had a collab with
uh
adidas i don't think it was a big deal
though the kobe's the kobe
adidas and then
the shoe now like in the this generation
as well as the kyries right
yeah that was the hoop with and the kds
and the pgs as well
pg-13 wait kd has dope shoes yeah he has
really good shoes maybe i should get him
out playing him the kyrie is whatever
you want yeah kyrie's feel like you're
hooping with a pillow
oh really yeah what else you got jen
this is uh
terrible news but a 22 year old surfer a
top el salvador surfer
was struck by lightning and died in the
water
how crazy is that i mean i have so many
questions so he
got struck she was a girl struck by
no she died from the light they couldn't
revive her after the
yeah after the strike couldn't remember
well i don't know where we go with that
it's just such a that wasn't
crazy no no there's plenty more rest in
peace
all right lamar odom's getting serious
now he actually knocked out a partner in
sparring no i'm not mad at the [ __ ] oh
you saw this i'm yeah i'm not mad at his
pants
i'm not mad at this
is their jazz music because the trainer
is an old school guy he trains
kevin hart he'd like to play with jazz
is that kevin hart is that the guy who
spartans
terrible yeah is that legit punching
with the way he's doing that i don't
know what that is he's like ducking in
that was terrible that looked fake too
so yeah that was terrible
oh he's probably just letting nick
carter know hey bro i'm coming or eric
his timing was like a little bit better
that was terrible dog what are you
talking about okay
it does look weird look like his he
stands
his stance because he's so tall yeah how
tall is tomorrow
six eleven six eleven seven foot yeah
there yeah
super bowl he was super so yeah i don't
know his career so yeah
clippers clippers lakers acres one of
the champions he won how many
were the lakers uh two kobe got him too
super baller kobe got him two yeah he's
badass huh
yeah 2011 sixth man of the year yeah it
came out it was a ballerina he was a
beast
16. what was this clippers jersey man
you did
the clippers oh you used og welcome
brand it was up there ultima
oh really um uh he was a small forward
but he could handle like a [ __ ] small
game point such a ball
oh damn it's a shame what happened now
yeah i mean he's fighting aaron carter
[Music]
save your money back to the girl who got
struck by that
any other depressing things no this is
funny i saw this on barcelona oh
she i saw this as well oh my god
i think it blew up
she's all scared she's baby [ __ ] the
placement
terrible place never grill grill why
would yeah why is it up there
yeah on the cliff she grabbed it and
she's going down yeah yeah
it was lit too yeah um some more stuff i
saw this is
cool oh two years old so cute
yeah killing it pizza fries pizza fries
pizza fries that's how you got it yeah
pizza to slow down
fries you go pizza fries
i can't believe a two-year-old could do
something like that
[Applause]
did daddy help that's adorable
yeah she killed it that was dope
chanting thank you
thanks for that that was a good one so
you know there's rumors that uh
once the like parks like you know
anaheim
disneyland all those places once they
open up you're you're supposed to get
there's a report so you couldn't scream
anymore because yeah but apparently
those are false sports
oh yeah i'm just talking i was gonna
scream anyway yeah yeah you're not gonna
be able to stop people
he was screaming
we saw the picture your mouth is open i
know what they are doing uh when they
open up you can only be a california
resident
you can't be from out of town i like
that oh really which i like
yeah it gives me less crowded yeah way
less crowded
out of town check this dude out
this guy look at his training oh he's
about to fight uh that's the heavyweight
light heavyweight i should say
who's about to fight um i can't think uh
michael hunter i'm trying to think made
that famous there's been a guy oh uh
lomachenko does that oh really build
your wrist
and then it does this
i don't know what his record is
i think he up there though right he's a
beast oh yeah he's a definite beast
not that one i think that's pretty much
it for current events that's good man
all right oh
she goes are you gonna go work out after
this yeah
honey bun pale sticky bum failure sticky
bun
i want everybody to say that i'm looking
slimmer i appreciate it because i am
working my ass out there
i keep looking at my [ __ ] before
picture which i cannot wait till
yo oh hey you know like brenda
look what y'all doing dawg i try to like
repeat try to emulate imitate him and
then i look over
and he just i'm just staring at them
keep you motivated oh god
i think about it all the time i can't
wait to show people that good is huge
man
right getting lower though yeah how
[ __ ] crazy does it look but bro you
look good now
stay away from the sticky buns right
let's not have any more hiccups
i had one you got you had a smokey bun
and you had a cookie it's okay
back to back days just saying don't want
to keep on one cookie meanwhile i'm
eating great the
rest of the time i mean you cheat me you
did have chicken tenders off my plate
and then you ordered your own
and then you did have uh biscuits and
gravy meanwhile i saw this [ __ ]
eating doritos late at night
i had seven doritos that's correct yeah
okay i had one [ __ ] cookie yeah you
did and i'm going crazy
you know what's so crazy i love how
you're like on the road we're gonna be
so strict on our diet they all cheat
you cheated this first couple times it
was great then you understand like
because we didn't have uh food well we
didn't go to whole foods
we went down there we went to albertsons
i mean hopefully well we are tired
though
we have to get going all right we'll do
better in miami i hope so
speaking of miami will be in miami this
weekend the march 25th to 27th thursday
friday saturday miami improv get your
[ __ ] tickets now
uh then back in florida april 15th to
17th in naples florida never been there
don't even know where it's at but you'll
see me there and then just announced
austin texas
april 22nd through the 24th at the
vulcan gas theater is austin texas right
off sixth street there
i'm in austin texas baby the squad's
there f-a-t-k-z.com for tickets
miami see you this weekend we're out
yeah
uh my dad's in og so i decided
to rock the ogs okay lg ones shout out
to suplex for these
bad boys right here like some philly
plays in philly man they let
they let you know you know thanks for
helping me keep it og
white okay yeah he was a little
aggressive during shoe cam today
these are bb things you know these are
the ovo's and then that's the
dunk shout out to suplex yeah i mean
you see him that's our boys in philly
shout out to mikey
brandon friends shout out though yeah oh
yeah for three weeks brenda had him
already but here's the thing
though you know what i mean when it
comes to hot bbs you know
i speak a little bit i speak a little
bit let's feel a little bit
uh
you've never been
white samples are they real i don't know
they're real to me they're real to me
go find somebody else with these bad
boys get them off white samplers
miami see you this thursday friday
saturday